par exemple à partir de la troisième
seconde tout ça pognait devrais me faire
faire des stages 3964 l'archivé
prémonitoire à l'époque pas encore de
stage en entreprise pour les élèves
mais pour cette jeune lycéenne l'idée
est déjà présente
vingt ans plus tard en 1984 laurent
fabius alors premier ministre ouvre la
voie à un rapprochement entre
l'entreprise et les collèges et lycées
il faut que tous lycées de france que
tout collège de france soit jumelé avec
une entreprise ici pas encore de stage
mais un jumelage entre une entreprise et
un collège ou un lycée
le but faire découvrir aux élèves le
monde du travail
plusieurs fois dans l'année scolaire il
faut qu'on comprenne que ya pas deux
mondes qui soient séparés mais qu'il
faut que ceux qui travaillent dans
l'entreprise apporte leur formation à
l'école et que ceux qui sont à l'école
comprennent déjà quels sont les besoins
de l'économie
suite à cette annonce les premiers
jumelages sont mises en place dès la
rentrée scolaire 1984 mais l'initiative
n'est pas obligatoire elle est prise
d'un commun accord entre les professeurs
le chef d'entreprise et les élèves à
l'image de ce jumelage entre une classe
de troisième et une petite entreprise de
sondages quimpéroise une classe de
troisième il ya beaucoup de perspectives
à ouvrir alors que par définition il y
en a qui font l'informatique d'autres
qui feront tout à fait autre chose et je
crois que la petite entreprise comme
optima arrivera je dirais à faire les
choses de très chouettes avec une petite
place ce chef d'entreprise est conquis
du côté des élèves aussi le jumelage est
bien accueillie c'est intéressant ce
genre est une entreprise c'est comme si
une communauté comme la clastre c'est de
partir de l'industriel
c'est du travail l'année suivante en
1985 terminé le jumelage et place aux
stages d'observation terme qui fait son
apparition pour la première fois autre
nouveauté les troisièmes ne sont plus
les seuls concernés les élèves de 4e le
sont également
exemple avec cette classe de meurthe et
moselle qui a pu découvrir les coulisses
de l'aérodrome de nancy pendant trois
jours pour les enfants c'est une très
bonne chose tant à l'école n'ont qu'une
idée du travail
est ce que cela peut représenter et nous
avons fait le maximum pour leur donner
toute l'information et puis se rend
compte de même depuis 2005
ce stage d'observation est obligatoire
et dès cette année là il ne concernait
plus que les élèves de 3e un stage
facultatif cette année en raison du
coffee 19 à la place des modules vidéo
et des formations sur le monde du
travail seront proposés aux élèves
[Musique]